una muestra de compromiso por parte de
eeuu este buque de asalto de 257 metros
el yu s skill search con 1200 marines a
bordo llegó a estocolmo justo antes de
un ejercicio militar anual destinado a
preservar la seguridad en la región del
mar báltico
este es un gran acontecimiento para los
eeuu es la primera vez que un barco
estadounidense un buque de la marina
estadounidense de este tamaño ha
navegado por el archipiélago sueco lo
que estamos diciendo aquí es que estamos
haciendo un compromiso con suecia y
finlandia un compromiso de intención al
participar en grandes ejercicios como
altos
el ejercicio back tops 22 es superior al
del año pasado con 45 buques 76
aeronaves y la participación de 16
naciones incluyendo los 14 miembros de
la otan más finlandia y suecia que
recientemente han dado marcha atrás en
décadas de no alineación militar en un
intento de unirse a la organización
hasta ahora su entrada ha sido bloqueada
por turquía si se suman a la alianza la
costa del mar báltico quedaría casi
totalmente rodeada por miembros de la
otan
así que desde la perspectiva rusa eso
será muy problemático para ellos
militarmente hablando y sería muy
ventajoso para la otan
el presidente ruso vladimir putin le
advirtió que moscú reaccionaría si eeuu
se reforzaba la infraestructura militar
en los dos países nórdicos
la primera ministra sueca magdalena'
anderson dijo que la presencia de eeuu
era una demostración concreta de
compromiso en el transcurso de val tops
de este año las naciones participantes
practicarán asaltos en escenarios que
simulan territorios tomados por un
enemigo
el ejercicio finalizará el 17 de junio